We've just shown how to position and orient a camera in world space. If we
apply this matrix C to some camera object, the camera then gets placed in the
world. However, we want exactly the opposite of this. We don't want to position
the camera with respect to the world, we want to position the world with
respect to the camera. Think about what's happening. We have some objects in a
scene, they've perhaps had a number of modeling transforms applied to them. The
objects are now all positioned in world space. What we want to do now is
transform the world to the camera's frame of reference. Here's a camera and a
model. Say we slide the camera five units along the world's x axis. From the
camera's point of view, if we subtracted 5 from all the world coordinates,
everything would be nicely oriented for the camera. The long and short here is
that we use the inverse of the matrix that would position the camera in the
world. Inverting basically says, no. It's all about me, the camera. Reorient
everything with respect to me, me, me. This inverse matrix is called the view
matrix. For this reason, this view matrix is sometimes written as the inverse
of the camera matrix. The matrix that would move the camera to its place in
world space. Another way to think of this view transform is simply as the very
last modelling matrix in the chain. The M matrix represents all the transforms
needed to get the object into world space. Modelling transforms. Now one last
transform, the view matrix V takes the objects in world space and moves them
into camera's frame of reference. If you deal with WebGL or OpenGL directly,
you'll see these two matrices put together as a single matrix called the model
view matrix. This matrix is applied to an object, immediately taking it from
its own model space to view space.